frozen to has been a hit with both
adults and kids alike and although the
movie has plenty of slapstick comedy for
little ones to enjoy it also includes
some eyebrow-raising grown-up jokes and
references as well
yippie ki v lovers I'm John and in this
video I'm revealing the 12 most
surprising and shocking adult gags and
details that Disney's animators snuck
into frozen to come on there will be
some spoilers ahead so take care if you
haven't seen the movie yet
it began with two sisters when Kristoff
sings about proposing to Anna during
some things never change
he gets down on one knee and holds up a
ring directly in front of Sven who nods
vigorously in reply but it's the
reaction of the onlookers to the scene
that makes this a priceless adult joke
as they clearly think that Kristoff has
taken his theory that reindeer are
better than people too far and is
actually asking one to marry him one
horrified woman puts her hand in front
of her young daughters eyes to stop her
seen what's happening while another
woman not only turns her head away from
Kristoff and Sven but as an extra
precaution also blocks her eyes with her
hand this isn't the first time the
unusual connection between Kristoff and
Sven has been referred to in the frozen
franchise in the first movie the trolls
poked fun at their special relationship
when they sang the fixer-upper song
which included Christoph's various flaws
such as his thing with the reindeer
that's a little outside of nature's laws
that's normal in frozen too Kristoff is
of course devoted to honor but the new
movie still has some funny callbacks to
the original movies romantic tension
between the pair for example Elsa and
Olaf fall asleep on their cart ride to
the enchanted forest and as soon as
honor notices they're no longer awake
she asked Kristoff what he'd like to do
it's clear from both her tone and body
language when she asked the question and
the fact that she leans in for a kiss
that she's got loving on her mind and
then when Kristoff Olaf and Sven get all
dressed up in fancy outfits for a
special occasion at the end of the movie
Kristoff just isn't comfortable with his
new clothes and tells honor you get this
for one hour
that's when honor whispers her rather
racy reply to him that's okay I prefer
you in leather anyway
charmed I'm sure that's followed by even
more dubler entendre zazz Olaf's
innocent
to Christophe that I'm shocked you can
last an hour will doubtless be
understood by some adults watching for
the reference to something other than
the characters smart new clothes
especially given Anna's previous
statement about leather don't patronize
me
after the gang encounter the wind spurt
in the Enchanted Forest it lifts Olaf up
in the air twirling him around playfully
and as he whirls around his bottom half
billows out around him like a dress
caught in the breeze this is a tribute
to the iconic scene in director Billy
Wilder's film the 7-year itch where
Marilyn Monroe's white dress blows up
around her after a blast of air from a
subway grate and Olaf even remarks that
the breezy experience is delicious just
like one row did in the 1955 classic
comedy about marital infidelity later
when Olaf first introduces himself to
the people trapped in the forest Ryder
gasps and hides behind his sister honey
Marin who are you
although Ryder's clearly shocked to meet
a talking snowman that never occurs to
Olaf who thinks the problem is something
quite different oh sorry yeah I just
find clothes restricting yes Olaf
believes that Ryder's so stunned when
they meet because he thinks a little
snowman isn't wearing any clothes so now
we know for sure that despite the three
stones resembling buttons on his front
Olaf actually prefers to go au naturale
just before we get to Elsa's hilarious
adult moment - frozen - I want to let
you know that thanks to this video
sponsor nord VPN all our viewers can get
a very special Black Friday deal of 84
percent off plus 4 bonus months for free
and free access to the Nord locker file
encryption app by visiting Nord VPN comm
slash flicks or tapping the link in the
video description frozen to pokes fun at
a particularly iconic moment from the
first movie after Elsa's show yourself
song Atta Harlan reveals memories to her
of past events including childhood games
with honor and the Duke of weselton
dancing but when she sees the memory of
herself strutting her stuff during let
it go
it makes her visibly cringe it's an
amusing moment of Elsa feeling
embarrassed of the actions of a younger
self something many adults will be able
to relate to but there's a second level
to this joke
not only is it about having outgrown
your younger self it may also be a wink
to those in the audience who saw or
heard that song so many times it ended
up driving them crazy that same moment
from Les it go was also parodied earlier
in the sequel when Olaf imitated Elsa's
signature self-assured sashay during a
game of charades Oh
the sequel also remedies complaints from
fans that Kristoff never got a full song
of his own in the first movie reindeers
are better than people Sven why is love
so hard this time Kristoff gets to belt
out his very own love song called lost
in the woods it's all about his
struggles to move forward in his
relationship with honor and there's
plenty about this new musical number
that aimed specifically at adults
there's a whole retro style of the song
which is basically a take on 80s power
ballads
according to Kristen anderson-lopez
one-half of the husband-and-wife
songwriting team behind frozen's mega
hits the 1980s was that brief moment of
music when men were allowed to sing
those big power ballads and to be
vulnerable while doing it personally
when I watched the film lost in the
woods had a strong feel of Peter Cetera
and Chicago's 80s power ballads like
Gloria blur the theme for the Karate Kid
Part 2 and of you're the inspiration
which featured in Deadpool but the 80s
vibe of lost in the woods doesn't end
with the music christophe also gets the
80's music video treatment complete with
music video wind for that signature
romantic breeze between the visuals and
the song itself the lost in the woods
sequence nicely balanced as amusing
images perfect for a retro music video
with Christoph's very real sincerity as
he sings about his love for honor
and speaking of classic music videos it
seems the frozen two team had one
particularly famous music video in mind
when they were animating lost in the
woods the waist fan and several other
reindeer appear as backing singers
around Kristoff during his new power
ballad channels the look of the
groundbreaking promotional video that
Queen made in 1975 for their super hit
Bohemian Rhapsody the British rock bands
video has been so influential that it's
credited with practically inventing the
music video and many
adults in the frozen to audience will
immediately spot some of its signature
style the spell and his fellow
quadrupeds orbit Kristoff as they
provide reindeer harmonies for his lead
vocals fun fact as well as voicing
Kristoff actor Jonathan Groff also
voices all the reindeer in the song you
feel what you feel and those feelings
are real come on Kristoff let down your
guard when Elsa and Anna discover their
parent shipwreck in the enchanted lands
they wonder why and how their parents
ended up their honor has the idea to
look for answers in the waterproof
compartment that every errand alien ship
has which prompts Olaf to muse
that's very clever although it does make
me wonder why they don't just make the
whole ship waterproof this is actually a
slide joke about aeroplanes and their
flight recorders aka black boxes which
are designed specifically to survive
airplane crashes so the flight data they
store can be used by accident
investigators to determine the cause of
a crash a fact which often leads people
to joke why aren't aeroplanes made from
the same material as black boxes one of
the main themes of the film is change
and how we adapt to it and Olaf is a
crucial character in getting that point
across how I wish this could last
forever and yet change marks us with her
beauty Olaf was a bundle of innocence
when we met him in the first film
however now instead of dreaming up plans
for summertime Olaf is trying to come to
terms with the many changes happening
around him tell me you're older and thus
all-knowing do you ever worry about the
notion then nothing is permanent what's
especially amusing for adults in the
audience is that Olaf really believes
that everything he's going through in
life in general will all make sense when
he's grown up in fact Olaf song when I
am older includes a lot of lines that
adults will doubtless find very funny
such as I'll have all the answers when
I'm older when I'm more mature I'll feel
totally secure and when you're older
absolutely everything makes sense
grown-up viewers will find the irony of
Olaf's song comical as they know getting
older doesn't always mean you understand
everything better sometimes things just
seem even more ridiculous
well you're the grown-ups you know and
adults will also laugh because they'll
they thought the same was Olaf when they
were kids too in the three years between
the events of the two movies Olaf has
been reading and learning a lot and he
drives the other characters a little
crazy on their journey north with his
fascinating facts that range from the
chances of getting struck by lightning
to the shape of wombat poop
did you know gorillas burp when they're
happy but the little snowman has even
begun to ponder some wait here for the
Safa chol questions you guys cope with
the ever increasing complexity of
thought that comes with maturity no no
don't you that you don't know what I
stepped in in the enchanted forest when
honor asked Olaf for some help in
understanding the mysterious ice
sculptures created by Elsa's magic just
before he gets to his water has memory
explanation
Olaf mentions his theory about advancing
technologies being both our Savior and
our doom many adults will find this
reference both humorous and true given
the real-life benefits and threats that
stem from our ever advancing
technological world whether that's
connecting with friends and accessing
information and entertainment in just a
few clicks or actors brought back from
the dead to storing new movies
driverless vehicles and the rise of
artificial intelligence perhaps Olaf's
philosophical ponderings about
technology could even make a funny and
informative short series along the lines
of four key ask the question where Olaf
learns for example how to stay safe
online and protect his privacy and
actually that's something that Nord VPN
you offer one of the world's best
virtual private networks could help him
with if you want to secure yourself from
hackers malicious websites and even your
own Internet service provider selling
your online browsing history to
advertisers then a VPN is essential the
VPN creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and a VPN server
stopping your ISP or any other agencies
from tracking you online reading your
emails private messages or what websites
you're visiting
unlike free VPNs Nord is superfast with
more than five thousand servers in over
60 countries and when I put it to the
test I was still able to get
blisteringly fast download speeds over
my home connection Nord VPN is also
great in helping you bypass any blocks
on videos or websites which aren't
viewable in your country with Nord VPN
you can quickly pick a server and
country and then browse the Internet as
if you were there Nords VPN even unlocks
Netflix shows that may not be available
in your home country the interface is
amazingly intuitive and you can connect
up to six devices at the same time so
you can keep your mobile devices and
laptops safe whenever you're traveling
or using insecure public Wi-Fi in a
coffee shop for example on top of that
Nord VPN offers a unique feature called
cyber sec which provides ad blocking and
protection against malware and Nord has
a no log policy meaning it doesn't
record any of your browsing with our
special Black Friday and Cyber month
deal Nord VPN are offering all our
viewers up to 84 percent off new
subscriptions plus an additional four
months free and free access to the Nord
locker file encryption app just visit
Nord VPN comm slash flicks or tap the
link in the video description to access
the offer for just the price of a
monthly cup of coffee
you can secure your internet browsing
from spies and hackers that's Nord VPN
comm slash flicks for a huge eighty-four
percent discount plus four months
entirely free now what were your
favorite moments or jokes in frozen to
let me know in the comments below next
tap left to learn all about Elsa's new
powers in frozen 2 or tap right for
another video you're sure to like and if
you enjoyed this remember to share and
leave a thumbs up for more videos like
this thanks for watching and see you
next time you peek-a-boo be lovers